Transcription: Cécilia Canal
Relecteur: eric vautier
(Applaudissements)
Je vais commencer
par vous poser une question :
au 21e siècle, à quoi sert l’université ?
À rien, peut-être ?
Est-ce un lieu où l’on apprend des choses
qui vont devenir rapidement obsolètes,
dont on ne se servira jamais ?
Évidemment, pour moi, pas du tout.
Et dans ce monde qui change
à un rythme très rapide,
je suis convaincue
que le rôle de l’université
est encore plus important que jamais.
Alors, pour vous en convaincre,
je vais vous présenter deux étudiants
aux profils bien différents.
Je vous présente Julien.
Julien a 18 ans et il ne sait
pas ce qu'il veut faire.
Entrepreneur et monter sa boîte,
ou avocat, journaliste,
ou bien encore consultant,
data scientist, archéologue,
ou bien même Youtubeur,
influenceur ou éco-concepteur.
En fait, sa motivation et ses résultats
pâtissent un peu du manque de maturité
de son projet.
Et puis, vous avez Inès.
Inès, elle, a 17 ans.
Elle sait parfaitement
ce qu’elle veut faire.
Elle veut être pédiatre.
Elle est très motivée par les études
et ses résultats au bac
lui ouvrent toutes les portes.
Alors, avec leurs envies,
mais aussi leurs différences,
leurs doutes, leurs incertitudes,
est-ce que Julien et Inès se tourneront
naturellement vers l’université ?
Et puis, de quoi ont-ils besoin ?
De quoi ont-ils envie ?
Et surtout, qu’est-ce que l’université
peut leur apporter ?
Alors, je sais que sur la scène du TEDx,
on n'est pas là pour vendre.
Mais aujourd’hui, exceptionnellement,
je vais vous faire de la pub,
de la pub non pas pour mon université,
mais pour l’université,
celle que l’on doit construire ensemble,
celle qui va permettre à Inès et à Julien
de décider, de construire leur parcours,
de le réaliser, et puis surtout,
d’être acteurs de leur monde.
Alors, comment ?
Eh bien, tout d’abord,
il va falloir réaliser
qu’apprendre un métier aujourd’hui
n’est plus une fin en soi.
Aujourd’hui,
nos jeunes auront plusieurs métiers,
des métiers qui vont évoluer,
dans une société en pleine mutation
dans laquelle d’ailleurs, ils devront
participer en tant que citoyens.
Il est connu que la plupart exerceront
un métier qui n'existe pas encore.
C’est pourquoi
l’université aujourd’hui évolue,
doit évoluer, continuer à se transformer,
alors, non pas avec une réforme de plus
dictée par l’État,
mais avec une transformation interne
profonde
où l’on doit apprendre à apprendre,
apprendre à s’adapter
et apprendre à contribuer à cette société
en pleine mutation.
Emma Jeunot : Excusez-moi Mme Retailleau ?
Sylvie Retailleau : Ah, Emma, tu es là ?
EJ : Vous parlez de l’université,
vous parlez de l’avenir de l’université
et donc de notre avenir à nous,
les étudiants.
Mais vous ne pensez pas qu’il serait
plus intéressant de parler avec nous,
plutôt que pour nous ?
SR : Tu as raison. Allez, viens.
Et puis mettons l’étudiant ensemble
et au centre de l’université.
Alors, je te laisse te présenter ?
EJ : Bonjour à tous,
je m’appelle Emma, j’ai 20 ans
et je suis étudiante
à l’université de Paris-Saclay.
Je vais vous présenter
mon parcours scolaire.
Moi, après mon baccalauréat, je suis
rentrée dans une université de psychologie
et je me suis vite rendu compte
que ces études
ne me correspondaient pas finalement,
et que je devais me réorienter.
Donc, je suis allée voir la conseillère
d’orientation de ma faculté
qui a conclu,
peut-être un peu trop rapidement,
que c’était le cadre de la faculté
qui ne me correspondait pas,
plutôt peut-être que de chercher à savoir
si c’étaient les études, finalement,
qui ne me plaisaient pas.
Là, Madame la présidente, il y a
peut-être eu un petit problème d’écoute
et d’aide à la réorientation,
mais néanmoins,
j’ai commencé mes recherches personnelles,
en regardant des vidéos sur YouTube
ou même en contactant des étudiants
sur les réseaux sociaux,
des étudiants dans d’autres filières.
Et du coup, tout ça, ça a conforté le fait
de faire le choix des études de santé,
Et j’ai osé, du coup,
m’inscrire dans une autre université
pour passer le concours
des études de santé,
que j’ai réussi, car aujourd’hui,
je suis étudiante en pharmacie
et finalement,
cette année de réorientation,
je ne l’ai pas vécue comme un échec,
mais plutôt comme une construction
de mon orientation,
et j’ai bien compris à ce moment-là,
que l’université
me considérait comme une étudiante active
dans sa recherche de réorientation.
SR : Oui, tu l’as dit,
entrer à l’université,
c’est d’abord changer de statut.
C’est effectivement devenir un
étudiant ou une étudiante.
Alors parfois, ça prend un petit peu
de temps pour endosser ce costume.
Mais si je reviens à un des points
essentiels de notre engagement
pour vous guider, pour vous accompagner,
je peux dire
que c’est d’abord la confiance,
la confiance entre l’étudiant
et l’université,
et puis, évidemment, la confiance en soi,
et je dirais même plus, l’estime de soi.
Parce que tu sais finalement, enseigner à
un étudiant qui sait pourquoi il est là,
qui est fier d’être là, et puis qui a
confiance en lui et en son université,
finalement, devient facile et évident.
Alors pour cela, il faudrait lui
laisser du temps,
le temps de se chercher,
le temps même de se tromper,
un peu comme toi,
le temps de construire son parcours,
finalement,
le temps de prendre un chemin de traverse,
mais sans que cela
soit considéré comme un échec.
Oui, je sais, tout cela n’est peut-être
pas très compatible avec un modèle,
probablement très français d’ailleurs,
de reproduction de clones,
fabriqués dans un moule bien défini.
Alors oui, il faut casser ce moule,
casser ces codes,
au profit peut-être d’un modèle
qui développe plus la curiosité,
la créativité.
D’ailleurs, ces deux qualités,
ces deux caractéristiques,
sont naturellement associées à la jeunesse
et peut-être
nous font parfois un peu peur,
car remettent en cause un certain confort
de notre enseignement classique.
Pourtant, dans le cadre de l’enseignement
supérieur, on a un atout.
En effet, notre enseignement supérieur
à l’université
est naturellement adossé à la recherche,
dont le doute et l’incertitude
sont la base.
D’ailleurs, tu sais, Nietzsche disait
il y a bien longtemps :
« Ce n’est pas le doute,
c’est la certitude qui rend fou. »
EJ : Et moi, des doutes, j’en avais plein.
Et justement, quand je suis rentrée à
l’université, ça a tout d’abord conforté
les peurs que j’avais,
les doutes que j’avais.
Et j’avais aussi peur de ne plus
correspondre à un système
où le temps et la performance
sont comptés.
J'avais peur que cette année de
réorientation soit perçue comme un échec
qui serait pénalisant pour la suite
de mon parcours, pour moi.
Et finalement, lors de ma recherche de
réorientation, je me suis rendu compte
que la plupart des étudiants que j’avais
contactés s’étaient réorientés.
D’autre part, j’ai aussi pris conscience
de la diversité de l’université,
de tous les champs et de toutes
les possibilités qui s’ouvraient à moi,
parce qu’on m’a dit que je pouvais
faire mes études de santé
et que je pouvais également
faire du droit.
On m’a dit que je pouvais faire les études
de santé et aussi du commerce,
et on m’a même dit plus tard
que je pourrais
reprendre ma licence de psychologie.
Et je pense que c’est cet aspect-là de
l’université qui serait à valoriser,
parce que tout ça, j’aurais aimé le
savoir avant de me réorienter.
SR : Oui, je vois,
ton expérience et ton ressenti aussi,
illustrent bien l’évolution de ce modèle
et vers un modèle
où l’on cultive plutôt la diversité
que la conformité.
Et puis, un modèle aussi,
qui laisse le temps aux étudiants
et leur permet de profiter
de toutes les richesses de l’université,
du champ énorme
de disciplinaire et pluridisciplinaire.
Finalement, un modèle qui doit
apprendre à apprendre.
Et puis là, on revient un peu
au fondamental de Montaigne qui disait :
« Mieux vaut une tête bien faite
qu’une tête bien pleine. »
Alors là aussi, comment ?
Eh bien, peut-être faudrait-il que l’on
commence par alléger
nos maquettes d’enseignement,
en contenu et en horaires,
et puis revenir aux fondamentaux,
et laisser du temps
pour apprendre en profondeur.
Alors, par exemple, proposer aux étudiants
et selon leurs besoins,
soit des approfondissements,
des compléments, du soutien aussi,
ou bien du temps pour le travail personnel
ou le travail en groupe par projet.
Et puis aussi des ouvertures
que l’université doit proposer,
comme par exemple l’entrepreneuriat,
l’initiation à la recherche,
l’ouverture à l’international,
et puis aussi la culture, le sport,
et beaucoup d’autres choses encore.
EJ : Et justement, si vous me demandez
ce que l’on veut nous,
aujourd’hui, les étudiants,
on veut du concret,
on veut pouvoir concrétiser
ce que l’on a appris,
concrétiser les bases que l’on a apprises,
qui sont si fondamentales finalement.
Par exemple,
avec des stages sur le terrain,
avec des travaux pratiques,
des études de cas.
Pour moi, c’étaient les stages dans le
monde pharmaceutique qui m’ont permis
de mieux appréhender ce que j’avais
appris, de mieux comprendre mes cours,
et même de me faire une idée
sur le futur métier que je voulais faire.
SR : Oui, ce que tu décris là,
c’est finalement une université
plus ancrée dans la société,
une université ouverte sur le monde,
avec des interactions,
tout au long de votre parcours,
avec le monde professionnel.
Alors, juste avant quand même,
tu n’as pas parlé de l’international.
Or, au 21e siècle,
avoir une expérience à l’international
est juste indispensable pour l’étudiant.
Alors, ça semble difficile,
voire impossible à proposer
à tous les étudiants, sauf peut-être à
développer une certaine mobilité virtuelle
avec des plateformes, des réseaux sociaux
utilisés à bon escient.
Alors, je reviens à ce que tu as dit,
c’est-à-dire,
effectivement, l’université doit préparer
aux métiers de demain,
je dirais ceux
qu’on ne connaît pas encore,
et puis, une vie qui peut être ponctuée
de différents métiers,
malheureusement, de périodes de chômage,
et donc un modèle qui apprend à s’adapter.
Alors, ça tombe bien, c’est vraiment
ce que l’on est en train
de travailler en ce moment, par exemple
avec la définition de blocs de compétences
que les étudiants doivent acquérir
tout au long de leur parcours,
puis finalement aussi proposer
à des étudiants
et exploiter, s’appuyer sur ses qualités
humaines, comportementales,
cognitives, citoyennes,
que l’on valorise de plus en plus,
et puis aussi des valeurs qui donnent
du sens à ce que l’on fait.
EJ : Et d’ailleurs,
je me souviens très bien
que lorsque je suis venue voir
la conseillère d’orientation pour lui dire
que je cherchais le futur métier
que je voulais faire, qui me plairait,
elle m’a dit : « Emma,
le futur métier que tu vas faire,
peut-être qu’il n’existe
même pas encore aujourd’hui. »
Donc le but, c’était pas de trouver
le métier que je voulais faire,
mais la voie qui me plairait,
et cette voie, elle devait correspondre
à mes valeurs aussi
et elle devait donner du sens
à ma future vie professionnelle.
Car c’est connu, nous,
les étudiants d’aujourd’hui,
nous sommes beaucoup plus exigeants
concernant par exemple l’université
ou nos futurs employeurs.
Je pense par exemple
au développement durable,
à l’inclusion sociale,
l’ouverture d’esprit.
Ce sont des sujets que l'on veut voir
se développer concrètement.
SR : Oui, ce que tu prônes là,
c’est une université plus engagée,
une université même
qui peut amener des solutions
à des problématiques contemporaines.
Alors, on pense tout de suite aux enjeux
de transition climatique,
énergétique, écologique,
ou bien aussi à des préoccupations
économiques, sociales et solidaires.
Tiens, je vais te citer un exemple
d’un projet,
d’une opération qu’ont menée
nos étudiants, plutôt nos étudiantes,
qui s’appelait « Jamais dans le rouge ».
Elles distribuaient
des protections périodiques,
et là, c’était une forme de lutte contre
la précarité et aussi
une certaine forme de discrimination.
Alors, tu vois,
ces préoccupations sont vraiment
au cœur de nos priorités aujourd’hui,
et elles sont même déjà incluses
dans nos formations.
Cette année, nous avons monté deux Spoke :
l’un sur les enjeux
de la transition écologique,
et il y a eu 2 500 étudiants inscrits
dès la première année,
et l’autre sur Esprit critique,
sciences et société, avec 3 500 étudiants.
Tu vois là l’appétence des étudiants
sur ces sujets.
Alors oui, nous développons
bien un modèle qui forme
des citoyens responsables,
un modèle qui apprend à contribuer à
une société ouverte et inclusive.
Alors oui, c’est ça que doit faire
l’université du 21e siècle :
apprendre à apprendre,
apprendre à s’adapter,
et apprendre à contribuer à notre société.
Et encore, je ne t’ai pas
parlé de la recherche,
l’autre mission cœur de l’université,
peut-être une prochaine fois.
Et en tout cas, cette université,
ce n’est plus l’université d’hier,
c’est une université toute neuve,
l’université de l’avenir,
de ton avenir Emma,
de celle de Julien, d’Inès,
de tous les étudiants qui trouveront,
je l’espère, dans l’université,
des réponses, des perspectives
et beaucoup d’espoir.
SR : Merci.
EJ : Merci.
(Applaudissements)
(Public) Bravo.